Really? That's interesting. It is.
Have you been invited? No. No.
That's fucked up. I don't want to go.
I ain't going to anybody's fucking island.
But about my rule Ronson,
somebody wants to ask Monson,
the Virgin Dude,
Richard Bronson or whatever his name is,
Branson.
Branson Yank on his fucking island.
I want to hang out and skate with Branson.
Why? Why? When I could jet ski with
Chewy is, listen, I ain't, I don't know.
Hanging out with any dude who as
an island, get the fuck Outta here.
Mccone or island because they always want
you to go to the islands. Like, bitch,
I ain't going to your island or
whatever. Just go to the diner. No,
a little awhile. Who? Who's that? Eddie
Murphy. Eddie Murphy as an island.
What would you get a photo daddies? I
might go daddy's. You got it. Got It.
I like Getty. I met Eddie and I was good
friends with his brother and good guy.
Charlie was the best. Charlie was the
greatest guy of all time. Yeah. Uh,
I met Eddie when,
when I met Eddie Murphy,
I met Eddie Murphy and Maui and he'd go
it first words out of his mind. He goes,
you are funny motherfucker.
I was like, God damn. Yes,
this is recently now years ago.
Maybe more than 10 years ago. Yeah.
That's like 2007.
Something like that would be unreal.
And I worked crazy funny in a Hoodie
with my family. I'll say thank you.
Like, what do you say when Eddie Murphy
says you're funny motherfucker. I'm like,
Holy Shit. Wow. Felt great. You know,
she look at your wife and be like,
see chuckle every once in awhile.
But
honestly at home I'm not that funny.
My wife cracks most of the jokes.
Really? Yeah. I don't know.
I don't have to be funny. Like
I don't need it, you know,
it's one of the reasons why I like to
hang around with Joey Diaz cause he's
always funny and he's always the
funny guy. You know? I like it.
It's uh, you know, I like being
around funny people, man. I'm not,
the thing about comics, especially the
needy, annoying ones in the early days,
like early days of your career, they
have to be the center of attention. Yeah.
That shit is really annoying.
Yeah,
and one of the things that you learned
for sure about hosting a podcast is you
don't really want to be
the center of attention.
You just want to facilitate
a conversation. Right.